today on the matt walsh show millions of
children are being experimented on
abused and mutilated all in the name of
gender ideology the problem has reached
epidemic proportions so much so that
even some mainstream media outlets have
started to notice
shockingly we'll talk about that today
also five headlines including
the mayor of chicago announcing that
she'll only accept interviews from
non-white reporters
one elected politician in washington had
the courage to condemn her for this
for this kind of bigotry and to do it
specifically and it wasn't a republican
also
is prince harry a victim of emotional
abuse we'll ask that question and
buzzfeed
reports that the white house wants to
help americans have more sex with random
strangers this summer
in our daily cancellation we'll consider
the mother on tick tock who's worried
that her white male baby will grow up to
be quote awful and has developed a plan
to prevent that from happening
we'll talk about that and much more
today on the matt wall show
now we're going to check in with the
great courses plus you know i think
one of the best maybe the best measure
of someone's intelligence it's not an iq
test it's not any kind of written test
at all
i think it's just have a conversation
with someone and uh
is this someone who can speak
intelligently on a wide range of issues
uh do they have is there a depth to
their to their you know thought process
that kind of thing um and it's great if
you can
speak intelligently confidently about a
subject multiple subjects
i think some of that's being lost in our
culture today and that's why you need to
check out the great courses plus with
the great courses plus you'll get
thousands of hours of fascinating
content across hundreds of topics
uh from you know everything from science
to history astronomy whatever whatever
whatever subject you want i mean
literally any subject at all you can
imagine they've got a course for it with
access to video audio and guidebooks
you can watch or listen anywhere at any
time with the great courses plus app
i use this all the time it's another
thing i used in my long long car ride
makes car rides go by a lot faster so
don't miss out on this great deal go now
to thegreatcoursesplus.com
walls to get your free month when you
sign up for a quarterly plan again
that's thegreatcoursesplus.com
walsh so i spent the weekend driving
from tennessee to maryland
and then back again 1500 miles give or
take it was almost
long enough to make me wish that i'd
taken a plane instead almost
but not quite the good thing about the
drive is that it gave me a chance to
listen to
and almost finish abigail schreier's
book on how
gender ideology is destroying an entire
generation of children
the book titled irreversible damage the
transgender craze seducing our daughters
uh you've probably heard of it came out
last summer and i i'd put off reading it
partly because i'm i'm very well
informed on this issue or i thought i
was
and uh i'm cynical in general so i
didn't think the book had anything to
tell me that i didn't already know
or assume i was wrong uh the crisis as
schreier documents it
is much worse than i thought and i
already thought it was very very bad and
i've told you that many times
i had to pause the book frequently
throughout
just to collect myself and at certain
points to stave off
bouts of nausea so that i didn't start
vomiting all over myself and i don't
even say that as a joke
the chapter describing phalloplasty
that's when plastic surgeons use bits of
a woman's body
to construct an appendage that's
supposed to look like a penis
had an especially sickening effect on me
i won't go into details here except to
give you one little morsel of
information part of the process
involves de-sleeving the forearm and
that's exactly what it sounds like they
pull the skin
off of a woman's arm like a sleeve and
then they use it in the construction of
the fake
male reproductive organ only it's not a
reproductive organ at all of course
you can't actually give a female a male
body or a male a female body that's
impossible
all you can do is take a healthy body
and mutilate it
you can make a body less feminine you
can't make it male
a male body is male down to its very
bones down to its cells its dna the only
way to turn a woman into a man
would be to obliterate her body
completely and build a man from scratch
which
which also is impossible right now but
that wouldn't even be turning a woman
into a man that would just be killing a
woman
and creating a man to take her place but
the main the main point of the book is
not to describe
sex change surgeries which have plastic
surgeons basically acting like leather
face from the texas chainsaw massacre
all the name of alleged medicine um the
the main point of the book is
to show in painstaking detail how
children girls
are the special focus of this book are
indoctrinated into
gender ideology at very young ages and
you're eagerly put on the path to gender
transition if they show even the
slightest
sign that they're questioning their
gender and of course it's not hard to
get a child to question
their gender almost any child will if
the idea is suggested to them
early enough that's how millions and
millions of children
are fed into this system you truly can't
understand the full scope of this
problem until you've looked at the
numbers
we are losing an entire generation to
this madness and that is
not an exaggeration gender ideology is
both jammed into the kids heads by the
school system academia hollywood and
media
and every other powerful institution and
also spread
among the kids themselves it's it's a
full-on social contagion unlike any that
we've seen in our lifetimes
and the problem is that and i think the
book does a really good job of
explaining this
in in particular is that all of this
stuff the gender ideology
has a very special appeal to kids
in particular girls as they go through
puberty and they endure
a perfectly natural period of feeling
uncomfortable in their own bodies
kids have always felt that way in
puberty after it before it
people have always felt that way at one
time or another to one degree or another
but now i mean we everyone has had an
experience of looking in a mirror and
not being totally
happy with what you see we've all been
there
but now we're given a framework for
interpreting
those natural feelings and the framework
tells us that if we feel
not totally at home in our bodies then
we're gender dysphoric and we should
embark on a quest to get a new body
as the book describes doctors and
therapists will diagnose gender
dysphoria
almost automatically in many states
they're essentially obligated to legally
the so-called affirmative care standard
means that counselors and therapists
must affirm a patient's gender delusions
even if the patient is a child so if if
a 10 year old boy comes in and says i i
think i'm a girl
there's no effort to figure out why he's
saying that
what lies at the at the root of it what
is he really trying to express
where is this coming from none of that
none
the only thing they do is say well okay
then you are
so you're a girl let's talk about how to
you know make you
more into what you feel that you are
this in spite of the fact that the goal
of therapy should be quite literally
the exact opposite of that
when it comes to the gender stuff
therapy along with the medical industry
generally
has flipped itself on its head and
performed the opposite of the function
that it's supposed to perform now kids
are put on puberty blockers at the drop
of a hat then cross-sex hormones
and before long surgery girls as young
as 16 sometimes younger are having their
breasts cut off
an entire biological capacity
permanently removed
all in the vein hope that they can
become men
and sometimes they don't even want to
become men
they talk in the book about a about a a
quote-unquote doctor i think was in
canada
has done over a thousand of these
so-called top surgeries
and in some cases the girls aren't even
claiming to be gender
dysphoric they don't even say they want
to be men they identify as non-binary
they want to be neither
it's a cosmetic it's entirely cosmetic
they approach it like another person
would approach getting a tattoo only a
16 year old can't get a tattoo in most
places but they can get their breasts
chopped off
the doctors are not only performing
these procedures but recommending them
and profiting off of them of course
now just so happens that after my
weekend spent listening to these stories
i came home to find out that 60 minutes
in a true shocker performed
some actual journalism and aired an
investigation
this past sunday night into this very
problem 60 minutes
interviewed a number of uh d
transitioners those are people who went
through a medical transition to become
the opposite sex
then regretted it and tried to go back
and unfortunately
depending on how far along they are in
the process they can't fully go back
now there are many such cases and there
will be a great many more in the years
ahead
here's just one example um this is a
girl named grace
who went all the way through the
transition
um all the way through the double
mastectomy having her breasts removed
before changing her mind and here she is
describing that
process did the therapist not
question you about how deep
the feeling was and what it was stemming
from
she didn't go really go into what my
gender dysphoria might have been
stemming from we only did a few sessions
because she was over 18 and didn't need
parental consent
she says she merely signed an informed
consent form at a clinic
and got hormone shots they asked me so
why do you want to go on testosterone
and i said well being a woman just isn't
working for me anymore
and they said okay so that was that
you've got your prescription for
testosterone
yep just four months after she started
testosterone
she says she was approved for a
mastectomy what's called
top surgery that she told us was
traumatic
you know i'm kind of surprised because
based on everything you've set up to now
i would have thought you'd
have a great sense of relief i started
to have a really
disturbing sense that like a part of my
body
was missing almost a ghost limb feeling
about being like there's something that
should be there and the feeling really
surprised me but it was
really hard to deny and so she
detransitioned
by going off testosterone and then
went back to the clinic and she says
complain to the doctor that the process
didn't follow the w path guidelines
uh if it sounds like
the doctors and counselors she consulted
seemed to have no concern for her
physical well-being at all or her
psychological well-being that's because
they didn't
and they don't on that note
um i want to play another clip for you
this this one was mentioned in trier's
book
that's how i was made aware of it i'd
never seen it before
these are uh and i should have seen it
we should all see this but i want to
make sure a lot of people see this clip
these are comments made by a woman named
dr johanna
olson kennedy she's one of the most
prominent texas chainsaw physicians
sending countless young people off to
get mutilated
she's also the medical director of the
center for trans youth health and
development at children's
at the children's hospital los angeles
and she's also married to a trans man
that is a woman who identifies as a man
that's where she's coming from that's
her background here she is at a
conference in 2018
explaining why it's okay to chop the
breasts
off of an adolescent girl this again is
not
theoretical or academic people like this
woman are actually doing this to girls
thousands of them or referring them to
surgeons who will do it
here is her justification i want you to
listen very carefully to this
i'm just gonna say this that actually
people get married when they're under
20. actually
people choose colleges to go to actually
people make life-altering decisions in
adolescence
all the time all the time and honestly
most of them are good
it's just the bad ones that we talk
about oh my god the cinnamon challenge
right i mean why do we know about it
because it's it's a thing and it's it's
not
it's not common like most teenagers
aren't eating cinnamon
right but some are they're on youtube
and that's stupid but we don't put on
youtube the things that are really good
decisions right
oh my gosh my kid took the s-18s
not a very exciting after-school special
right but so what we do know is that
adolescents actually have
the capacity to make a reasoned logical
decision
and here's the other thing about chest
surgery if you want
breasts at a later point in your life
you can go and get them
the first thing to understand is that
the woman there is evil we're talking
about nazi scientist
evil we're talking about abortionist
evil
now she may sound like a lunatic in that
clip but she isn't
that'd be letter off the hook lunatics
don't get medical degrees
bad people can get medical degrees and
unfortunately a lot of them have
but not lunatics so if you're crazy
delusional you're not going to get
through medical school
but you could be a bad evil person and
make it through medical school
and she's a bad evil person
what's her argument here well she says
first of all adolescents can make
good decisions in fact she says most
decisions
adolescents make are good
they make life-altering decisions all
the time she observes which somehow
means that it's
good for them to make those decisions
and we should help them to make more
such decisions
ironically the one example she gives of
an adolescent making a good decision
is taking the sats but that's not a
decision
that kids make parents make that
decision
adults make it kids go along with it
indeed it turns out most of the of the
good the actual
good long-term decisions quote-unquote
adolescents make
are the ones that adults tell them to
make
kids need adults to help them think more
clearly when it comes to long-term
choices
long-term planning and this is another
thing that a doctor knows
if i know that a doctor knows it a
long-term planning is a function of the
prefrontal cortex
and teenagers do not have a fully
developed prefrontal cortex which is why
they do
dumb things all the time which is why
almost all of us
if we survived our teenage years should
be thanking god that we did because
there's a really good chance that we you
know
it only would take one or two things to
go wrong of all the dumb things we did
all the dumb destructive reckless things
i know i can look back at my teenage
years and think of plenty of those
why were you doing that you look back to
being a teenager and you think about
some of the things that you did
some of the things you said the way you
acted and you think that was like what
was i
was i what was i it's like a different
person i don't know who that person was
was because your brain wasn't fully
functioning the way that it is now
they literally can't make good long-term
decision decisions
at least not reliably they don't have
the neurological hardware in place just
yet
this is also why we say adolescents
can't consent to sex
our laws against child rape and
pedophilia are all based entirely on the
idea
that young children cannot make sexual
decisions for themselves
dr johanna wants to undermine the legal
scientific and philosophical case
against pedophilia
and that is not a coincidence by the way
check back in 10 years or maybe sooner
and she'll be explaining in one of these
videos with equal passion
why we must be tolerant towards an
accepting of adult child sexual
relationships
quote me on it 10 years from now maybe
sooner but even if she personally never
gets to that point
what she's already advocating for is
just
as bad a child who's put on hormones
and then who has their body mutilated is
being
sexually violated in a way that is just
as depraved and damaging
as molestation or rape all of these kids
are sexual abuse victims
and their abusers are people like the
doctor here she's like a pedophile
that's how she should be treated and
seen
somehow though we haven't even gotten to
the most deranged part of
that short clip she also says flippantly
practically laughing as she says it that
you could chop a young girl's breasts
off
and it's no big deal because she can
always go and get new breasts later if
she wants
this is what this doctor thinks of the
female body
she thinks of it like a lego playset or
a potato head doll
you could take parts off attach reattach
mix and match
a body is nothing but a pile of parts
cut a few off swap them out
nothing will be lost in the exchange
it is obviously not true i would hope i
don't need to explain that it's not true
your body is a whole coherent complete
thing it's not perfect nobody's body is
perfect
no person is perfect but it is your body
and yet you should love your body
because it's the only one you have
you can never have another one
this is what any therapist or counselor
worth their salt would be saying and
there are very few of them out there
that are worth their salt
by the way i mean we're at the point
where it's like i wouldn't even send my
kid to a counselor or a therapist period
i wouldn't send them
because i don't trust hardly any of
these people
given what they're saying
that's a different subject but your body
is your body you will never have another
one
a woman cannot have her breasts removed
and then go and get new ones you can't
her new breasts will not be breasts but
they'll be
mounds of flesh lumps of meat
now perhaps that's all that dr johanna
thinks breasts are to begin with
that's all she sees and and perhaps
that's understandable as her brain seems
to be nothing but
a lump of meat even so she's wrong
and you know something she knows she's
wrong
all of the doctors and therapists and
counselors
treating kids like frankenstein's
monster
they all know what they're doing
i mean when you when you feel like
you're the one going crazy because you
see stuff like this and you think
what is happening how can these people
not see how insane this is
well they do see it but they're
motivated by ideological conviction
politics and most of all money
there's a lot of money to be made and
social clout to be gained by
doing what they're doing especially when
most of the public is too afraid to
speak up against it
too afraid to say no this is wrong
a boy cannot be a girl a girl cannot be
a boy
this is all wrong
most people are too afraid to say even
that
except in hushed tones or privately
they'll send a message
hey i agree with everything you're
saying don't tell anybody
we cannot afford to be quiet about this
anymore this is one of the great fights
of our time it may be
the greatest either we can sit back and
watch while millions of kids are
experimented on and abused and tortured
and destroyed and literally cut into
pieces in front of us
or we can speak up and resist
and do what needs to be done that's our
choice
now let's get to our five headlines
you know some people are chair snobs
like me i have very specific demands for
chairs some people are more
chair inclusive and tolerant but no
matter where you fall
on the chair spectrum you will
definitely be able to enjoy and
appreciate the x chair xchair has you
covered for all of your office chair
needs
the secret is not only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support which
offers unbelievable lumbar support to
your lower back and eventually one of
these days
i'll figure out what lumbar support even
is but now thanks to their new
xhmt technology you can also get heat
and massage therapy while you're sitting
at your desk instead of your old
uncomfortable office chair now you can
look forward to spending hours sitting
in the ultimate therapeutic massager the
xhxhmt
delivers heat and massage technology
right to your core helping increase
blood flow muscle recovery
and energy all the perks that make
working from home or the office
a joy x chair is on sale now for 100 off
go to xchairwalsh.com now that's the
letter x chairwalsh.com
or call 18444x
chair that's one eight four four four x
chair extra has a 30 day
guarantee of complete comfort and you
can finance your purchase for as little
as 30
a month go to xchairwalsh.com now use
code x wheels for free x-wheel
bladecasters again
xchairwalsh.com
okay so um another note for my drive by
the way
lighter note a little bit lighter anyway
um
although still on the subject of of
perhaps medical induced
mania i i was uh it's actually the first
time i've seen this and we're a year
into this thing
first time i've seen what i saw
in uh virginia stopping at a panera
bread which was my first mistake
i admit why go to panera you know panera
bread it gets away with
positioning itself as sort of a a higher
class option from regular fast food
because they charge five times the
prices
so you figure well you're getting a
chicken salad sandwich for 27
it must be pretty good but actually it's
not really that good or you know they
sell
soup and bread bowls which
by the way that's you want to know why
we have an obesity epidemic in this
country it's because people are eating
like you're eating soup and you're
thinking to yourself
this is great but i really wish i could
eat the bowl too and then panera bread
is there to solve the problem
um anyway went into the panera bread and
uh
there were everybody in there wearing
masks
except me and
multiple tables of people sitting at
their table
food in front of them wearing masks i
i had not seen that yet
somehow there are people getting crazier
as time goes on
as the pandemic is recedes
um and most of the country is immune for
for one reason or another either vaccine
or prior exposure
there are people that are getting more
serious about it
i was just sitting there watching i was
waiting for my food i was waiting for my
57
order um and i'm watching people sitting
at their tables with masks on
and i never saw any of those people take
a bite because that's what i was waiting
to see how does this work are you
actually are you gonna try to eat that
thing with the mask on i really wanted
to see but
um anyway all right let's go number one
here
nbc chicago reports as chicago mayor
lori lightfoot approaches the two-year
anniversary of her inauguration reaching
the halfway point through her first term
she told the city's media outlets that
she would grant
one-on-one interviews to mark the
occasion but with one condition
she will only speak with journalists of
color
lightfoot tweeted wednesday morning i
ran to break up the status
i ran to break up the status quo that
was failing so many
that isn't just in city hall it's a
shame that in 2021 the city hall press
corps is overwhelmingly white
in a city where there were more than
half of the city identifies as black
latino
aapi or native american
what is aapi is that
pacific islander anyway i'm not going to
guess diversity and inclusion is
imperative across
all institutions including media in
order to progress we must change this is
exactly why i'm being intentional about
prioritizing media requests
from poc reporters on the occasion of
the two-year anniversary of my
inauguration as mayor of this great city
so you know first of all it's great that
this is her priority
as it's just bloodshed in the streets of
chicago
people kids women being shot and killed
as they walk down the street um so
that's happening
you know morgue's overflowing with
bodies not because of covid but because
of the violence and the
you know the gang culture in the city
she's not worried about that
she's worried about making sure there
are more black people reporters that's
there that are at the press conferences
and and her response is and let's be
clear also
when she's saying oh i only want to have
interviews with
black latino aapi whatever that is or
native american what she's really saying
is
i don't want to be interviewed by any
white people
so sometimes they get away with this
kind of thing because they sort of try
to frame it in a positive way
they say oh no we're just giving
opportunities to these uh to these
groups over here
but what you're really saying is you
don't want white people to interview you
because you only singled out one there's
only one group you left out you put
every other group in
it's kind of like when you are in third
grade and you invite everyone in the
class to your birthday party except for
one kid
and of course those of us with good
parents we were raised and told listen
you can invite the whole class or you
can invite one or two kids
what you can't do is invite most of the
kids except except one
that you can't do but
lori lightfoot we can assume for many
reasons was not was not raised well
um and so this is flat out bigotry and
racism against white people
it is anti-white racism
and that's what we should name it and
call it that because that's what it
is now there may have been some repo i'm
sure if i checked there are some
republicans who
complained about lightfoot saying this
maybe tweeted about it i'm not sure i'll
assume that some republicans did
uh maybe even called it racism but there
was one elected representative on the
national stage only one that i'm aware
of
that went so far as to say this this is
tulsi gabbard who i should remind you is
not a republican she's a democrat and
this is what she tweeted
mayor lightfoot's blatant anti-white
racism
is abhorrence i call upon president
biden kamela harris and other leaders of
our country
of all races to join me in calling for
mayor lightfoot's resignation
our leaders must condemn all racism
including anti-white
calling calling it not just racism
anti-white racism and then saying that
lightfoot should resign
now i love this statement from tulsi
gabbard she's
exactly 100 right um what i don't love
is that she's the only one saying that
and she's a democrat
what what a shame what an absolute
shaming well-deserved shaming of the
republican party
that this is not coming from any
republican is coming from a democrat
and the thing is as a democrat saying
this you you know tulsi this takes
courage
i actually have respect she might be
she's the one democrat one elected
democrat i can think of
who i have respect for um even though i
still i still don't agree with many of
your views but
this actually takes courage
because all of your colleagues and
democrat party
your base you know everyone that you
that you need to support you and
everything
they're all going to be against you for
this
because that's that's taboo you don't
talk about anti-white racism in fact
anytime
racism according to them doesn't exist
but republicans they would risk nothing
by calling it out
yeah the left's going to be mad at you
the democrats will be ready but they'll
be mad no matter what
um and most conservatives no matter
their race
black white doesn't matter are art would
be perfectly happy for you to call out
anti-white racism because that's what it
is
and it doesn't matter if you're a
republican who cares what the democrats
say they have no
it doesn't make a difference they're
going to hate you no matter what you
don't need them to like you
and they won't no matter what you say so
you have literally nothing to lose
you might as well speak up but these
cowards
they can't even endure they're gonna get
some frowny faces in the halls of
congress when they're walking by the
democrats
and they can't even that even that they
can't endure
tulsi gabbard put a lot more than that
on the line um
but we need to be very clear about this
as conservatives you know
uh if that is how you identify i think
we need to be very clear
it's not enough to just
blake it blanket statement condemn
racism
in response to something like this we
need to call it what it
is it is anti-white racism anti-white
racism
exists there's a whole lot of it in fact
it's the only form of racism in america
that's socially acceptable
um and it's one of the only forms of
racism that's also institutional and
systemic
arguably another form of being
anti-asian bigotry which
through a through affirmative action you
know that
is very real as well and systemic
um and yeah calling her for her to
resign the same way
i don't even i don't need to point this
out but i will
just if you can imagine a white mayor
saying that he only wants to be
interviewed by his fellow white people
he'd be a i think he'd be arrested i
think they would send the i think the
fbi would be knocking on his door and
they'd arrest him
for they'd find something
they would arrest him for felony
rudeness i guarantee it
hate crime charges you know you know i'm
not you know i'm right this is not
i wish it was like a joke or an
exaggeration but hyperbole it's not
they would call that a hate crime
but lightfoot can say it and you know no
problem all right
let's uh go here now see a little bit of
news from cnn
or news news about cnn we're not going
to get news from cnn but there's some
news about them and we'll start here
we heard something similar to this on
the last show that was from a democratic
representative and this is uh
another democratic representative named
don lemon
extolling the virtues of the democrat
party let's listen to that
how do you how does that correct
if you only have you know a fraction
of whatever the political spectrum
dealing with this issue
well right now the person who's in the
white house
is a democrat the people who are in
charge of congress are democrats
the people who are in the majority
slightly in the senate are democrats
the only party now that is operating in
reality
is the democratic party the republican
party is
obsolete okay
actually the last part of that i agree
with the republican party is obsolete
there's no denying that it is obsolete
and it's made itself obsolete largely by
the cowardice we were just talking about
a second ago
um and that and that we should also note
is don lemon
i want to be clear that's don lemon host
of
don lemon tonight as opposed to don
lemon host of tonight with don lemon
which i think that was that was the show
he had you know up until a week ago and
then they made a big announcement that
he was resigning from the show or
something it was this big deal
uh and then he comes back the next day
and says yes we we have ended tonight
with don lemon
we start a new chapter this is don lemon
tonight
um and it's it seems like the old don
the old don lemon much like the new don
lemon
and uh or new dominant like the old don
lemon however we want to put it
but he says the democrat party only one
living in reality same thing we heard
from the democrat
dominic i think was tim ryan last week
saying the same thing
there's only one republican there's only
one party living in reality it's the
democrats
well i guess i would ask don the same
question i asked tim
which is okay living in reality over
there uh can you get pregnant first of
all
in your reality the girl grace
the clip we played um
regretting her transition you know girl
like that take a 16 year old girl
chop her breasts off can you make her
into a boy i mean you're in reality
is that the kind of reality we're
talking about yeah i think it is
and then we've got chris cuomo at the
center of controversy because it was
found out
that he was advising his brother on how
to deal with the
sex harassment scandal even while
claiming on air that he wasn't
getting involved or anything and then it
came out that he's been
advising and uh and he actually
apologized for that and here's his
apology
people can say and write what they want
but i want you to know the truth
how i helped my brother also matters
when my brother's situation became
turbulent being looped into calls with
other friends of his and advisors
that did include some of his staff i
understand why
that was a problem for cnn it will not
happen again
it was a mistake because i put my
colleagues here
who i believe are the best in the
business in a bad spot
i never intended for that i would never
intend for that
and i am sorry for that it's also
important for you to understand
not only do i not cover this here i've
never
tried to influence this network's
coverage of my brother
in fact i've been walled off from it
this is a unique and difficult situation
and that's okay i know where the line is
i can respect it and still be there for
my family
which i must i have to do that i love my
brother
i love my family i love
my job and i love and respect
my colleagues here at cnn and again
to them i am truly sorry
you know who i am you know what i'm
about
and i want this to be said in public to
you who give me the opportunity
and to my colleagues who make me better
at what i do
okay a very teary moment there very
emotional i was getting choked up a
little bit i don't know about you
but his colleagues are the best in the
business which
you know maybe they are it's it's such a
low bar that
sure why not um
but here's the thing i i don't care
about this
at all really i'm not even sure why i
played that i was trying to remember
while i was playing that i was thinking
to myself why am i playing this do i
have something to say about this
because i don't remember what it was
supposed to be um
but even if i don't care about it uh
for me like i don't care he wants to
call himself a journalist that's
that's laughable that's a joke but as i
said the bar is so low for journalism
now that sure anyone can be one
if they want to be but i don't care he
he doesn't want to talk about his
brother's
sexual harassment scandal um
fine that's fine he's talking to his
brother advising him
i don't care about that either yeah it's
your brother so i understand you're
loyal to your family i
i really have an issue with that the
problem that that's not
really the problem that's not the actual
scandal because there is a scandal here
um the scandal is during
the height of all this back in in march
and april
cnn was bringing andrew cuomo onto chris
cuomo's show
on an almost nightly basis certainly at
least weekly basis and they were doing
these little buddy cop comedy routines
which is inappropriate enough given the
circumstances of all these people dying
but also there was no attempt to be an
objective
journalist they were they were handing
over their air time
for propaganda pieces between
this politician and his little brother
and then it turns out that this
politician is wrapped up in a scandal
that
resulted in thousands of elderly people
dying
so in terms of the journalism scandal
that's it
but as far as him not wanting to talk
about it now and and who cares if he
invite of course he
i would assume he's probably on the
phone with his brother who cares about
that
that's not the issue all right let's go
this is from page six it says
meghan markle didn't act on suicidal
impulses while pregnant with her son
because she didn't want prince harry to
be hurt by the loss of quote another
woman in his life
the duke of sussex told oprah winfrey in
the documentary series that premiered
friday
so oprah's doing another interview with
these people great he said in a
conversation with
winfrey in the uh the me you can't see a
new apple tv
plus series on mental health he said the
thing that stopped her from seeing it
through was how unfair it would be
on me after everything that happened to
my mom and to
that's british for mom and to now be put
in a position of losing another woman in
my life with a baby inside of her our
baby
um the prince told winfrey the scariest
thing for her was her clarity of thought
she hadn't lost it she wasn't crazy she
wasn't self-medicating
be it through pills or through alcohol
she was absolutely sober sober she was
completely sane
uh yet in the quiet of the night these
thoughts woke her up
harry said he did not go to his family
when markle felt suicidal because he was
ashamed the situation had got that bad
uh he also said the royals would likely
not be able to help
okay so meghan markle i mean i already
knew
that she was petty vindictive
self-absorbed all of that
a lot a lot of flaws shared by uh by
famous celebrities and so on so no
surprise there
but then you read stories like this and
you realize that if you didn't already
realize
oh she's just this is a really this is
evil this is a really really bad person
you're she's pregnant
with harry's son and threatening to kill
herself
this is emotional manipulation this is
emotional abuse
um and and
if if the genders were reversed
everybody would be saying that
can you imagine for a second meghan
markle
sitting down and saying that uh harry
was threatening to kill herself
and kill himself if if she didn't do
this or that thing
that he wanted everyone would be saying
this is a you need to get out of that
marriage
this is you're being emotionally
manipulated and abused
in in horrible ways because that is
horrible you're threatening to kill
yourself with you
while pregnant
um yeah that would be that's that's my
interpretation of it
of course i wasn't there but you know
what here's the other thing
because i know we are also told that
we're in no place to judge how dare we
you know maybe she really was going
through a psychological crisis of some
kind
um and we should butt out
but they are taking their personal life
and putting it out into the public they
are choosing to publicize
they don't have to nobody would know
anything about the suicidal stuff
unless they told us and they didn't have
to tell us this
not only are they telling us they're
getting paid to tell us
that they are in the process right now
of monetizing their personal story
and their their alleged personal trauma
and victimization
they're monetizing that they're turning
it into a media
empire into a franchise like a marvel
movie
so they are putting it out there in
public and when you do that
then yeah the rest of us we have every
right to give our opinion
and to try to and to you know
and if we want to speculate we can
speculate if you want people speculating
about it's like i always say if you want
people speculating or giving their
opinions about your personal life then
keep it to yourself
the moment you put it out there for the
entire public
as as as content for them to consume
you're the one who's turned it into that
that's your fault
and so i feel perfectly within my rights
ethically and certainly legally at least
for now
to say that to me um
that doesn't sound so much like
a mentally ill woman as it sounds like a
woman
emotionally and psychologically abusing
her husband
and as i said reverse the the the sex is
here
and that's how everybody would interpret
it
that's that is that's horrific stuff it
really is
all right um do we have time for this i
think now we're probably gonna save this
for tomorrow um because buzzfeed has a
story about
the white house who wants to encourage
people to go out
and have sex this summer randomly with
strangers and of course buzzfeed's a big
big fan of that
and yeah if you get vaccinated then you
can go and do that because apparently
uh the only disease you have to worry
about when having random stress with sex
with strangers
is coveted as long as you're vaccinated
you have to worry about anything else
we'll save that for tomorrow there may
be a longer conversation we had let's
move to
reading the youtube comments this is
from richard parker he says being a drag
queen who
twerks at nightclubs is officially a
more respected profession than being a
cop who puts his life on the line to
fight crime
morality is bankrupt in 2021. that's a
good way of
putting things in perspective and uh
you're exactly right georgian says this
drag queen stuff is disgusting and
degrading exactly what are they
attempting to teach
children how to be a drag queen
is this what their goal in life should
be keep up the good work matt we need
you
yeah they want to teach kids to be drag
queens uh
but that's more of a of a pleasant side
effect as far as they're concerned
the main thing is to just sexualize chil
children to desensitize them to this
kind of thing um that's that's the main
goal
to to destroy within the children any
nation uh semblance of
of quote-unquote traditional morality or
anything like that
that's what it is it's an attack on what
they consider to be
old-fashioned outmoded morality
this is this is one avenue through which
that attack is waged
uh and another comment says i want a
little old lady with a chain on her
glasses reading my stories
exactly that's that's one of the
less discussed aspects of the drag queen
story hour we're taking jobs away from
librarians and
they they when i was a kid they did a
perfectly fine job of reading stories
um deplorable neanderthal says matt the
daily i should do a backstage special
for the ufo report to congress i promise
i'll watch with baited breath
and you'll hit a billion views
guaranteed
a billion maybe because the aliens
themselves will tune in i don't know
i think that'd be great i will suggest
that i'll run that up the the flagpole
to see what happens
i will say that and this is a i think a
serious more serious conversation that
we should be having nationwide
because anti-ufo bigotry is uh is a big
problem
in the workplace and it's a big problem
in this
workplace here at the daily wire and i
don't mean to air dirty laundry like
megan and harry here but it's it's a
problem here um
and i would even say those of us who are
pro ufo
we are made to feel unsafe i mean i feel
unsafe sometimes
when i hear someone like michael knowles
coming out against ufos and saying that
it's basically impossible that there's
intelligent life
in the universe i feel unsafe
when i hear that this is really a
conversation for hr
i guess um let's see
kaya says safe travels to you and your
family on your vacation try to enjoy
also this episode's cancellation
literally made me simp but laugh out
loud for kyle
i mean the kid must have not known what
he was lurking into so naively
pity rest in pieces kyle uh and to that
i commandeered the expression god speed
i think you used i i don't think you
used simp correctly there
i think what you're trying to say is you
were sympathetic for kyle
because i you know back and forth you
thought i had the better of the the
exchange
i don't think that's i don't know
exactly what simp means but i don't
think that's it
so just for your own benefit don't go
around saying
that you simp for people if you're
sympathetic for them because i don't
think that's what it means
and uh finally this is from
pig marine great name says the bathwater
comment
is about belle daphne who took bath
and sold the bathwater under the name
gamer girl bathwater
i believe she sold a few batches and the
batches sold out in less than a day
okay so there's someone online
who's who took a bath and then sold her
bathwater and it sold out
what what
what do you do with it i mean the people
that are buying it what are they i guess
i don't want to know never mind don't
tell me
if you've never met candace owens that
could be about to change if you sign up
as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 20
off your new membership and be
automatically entered for a chance to
win a trip to the daily wire studios to
see candace live not only will he be
meeting candace you'll be getting inside
look at her studio our office
and front row seats to watch her live
and in action on her talk show
candace you may even see me walk by if
you do
don't talk to me leave me alone so don't
wait go enter to win a
candice vip pass now and dailywire.com
subscribe that's dailywire.com
subscribe using code vip for 20 off
and uh you know as you all know the
daily wire has been growing like crazy
we moved the whole company across
across the country we've you know we've
got candace owens we've got the deal
with gina chrono we've got a lot of
things going on
a lot of really exciting projects within
the last six months and beyond
um but we want uh to grow with you and
we want to know what you're all about
so we want you to go to
dailywire.comwalsh and fill out my
audience survey to tell us a little more
about yourself and
as it turns out at the survey you're
also telling
us what you think of me which i was very
disturbed when i found that out but
even so to sweeten the whole experience
those of you that complete the survey
will be entered to win a 1 000
gift card but you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show so uh
you also got to go listen to ben shapiro
michael knowles andrew clavin get access
to their surveys and you can be entered
to win
yet again again my survey link is
dailywire.comwalsh we'd love to hear
from you
let's get out to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today for our daily cancellation we
return to my favorite source for
cancellations tick tock now there are
some who say that i spend too much time
responding to content on tick tock
because tik tok is frivolous and
irrelevant and stupid and everyone knows
it allegedly
but this just goes to show once again
why conservatives themselves are
increasingly irrelevant in the culture
we tend to think that because something
seems stupid to us
unimportant to us a silly distraction to
us
that it must seem that way to everyone
else but that's not the case the fact is
whether you like it or not and i most
decidedly do not like it
tic toc is one of the places where
millions of people especially kids
go to get information and have their own
views affirmed
for that reason it matters even more
than mainstream media i mean i should
spend more time on this show responding
to tick tock
than whatever they're saying on cnn or
nbc because tiktok and platforms like it
move the culture and influence people
much more than does say
don lemon so with that preamble out of
the way a recent viral video must now be
brought under consideration here's a
young woman by the name of sarah
she made a video to tell the world about
the books that she'll be that she'll be
reading her very young son
bennett she's being applauded for this
and i am being mostly condemned for
having criticized her but you can make
up your own mind
let's uh watch the video first hi there
my name is sarah
this little cutie is my son bennett as
you can see
my son is a white male so here are some
books that i bought to help prevent him
from growing up to be
awful starting out strong we have c is
for consent um
pretty self-explanatory but it's a
picture book that goes into
detail about consent with your body with
family
along that same note we have will
ladybug hug teaches the same kind of
concept and in a more childish way about
a ladybug who
is hugging his friends he even has one
friend who doesn't like
hugging so this one is called only for
me
same concept teaching kids about consent
and things that feel comfortable
with their body because i'm raising a
feminist we've got a is for awesome 23
inspirational women next we have i clean
like daddy there's even a page in the
end where the whole family is cleaning
together to show that it's not just mom
and sister's job
finally we have except when they don't a
book about um boys and girls liking
whatever they want regardless of their
gender
okay so we have two major issues here
one is the book themselves the books
themselves and the other
is the stated reason for reading the
book so let's go with the latter first
sarah informs us that her son is a white
male which in some ways perhaps is
progress at least she didn't tell us
that her son is a white female or a
non-binary pansexual kangaroo or
something
she does at this point have a
fundamental understanding of biology it
seems and realizes that her son is
indeed male
um that's good the only hang-up is that
she seems to have a lot of suspicion and
resentment even towards her son
for being male now if forever for
whatever reason you don't
immediately understand why the phrase my
son is a white male so i have to prevent
him from being awful
is a problem imagine the same thing
but directed at a different kind of baby
imagine a mother with a black male child
saying as you can see my son is a black
male so here are a bunch of books i
bought so that he doesn't grow up to be
awful
or perhaps even better a father imagine
imagine a father pointing the camera
towards her his six-month-old daughter
and saying
as you can see my daughter is a female
so here are a bunch of books i bought to
prevent her from being a shrill
overbearing harpy
would there be anything to discuss in
either scenario no everyone everywhere
would unequivocally condemn
that sort of attitude only where it
pretends pertains to white males do we
suddenly want to make an exception
which proves not that sarah isn't
bigoted but that she's far from alone
in her bigotry of course there's nothing
wrong with parents endeavoring to make
sure that their children grow up to be
good people
as opposed to awful people every parent
on the planet
has looked to awful adults at some point
and said my god i need to make sure my
kids don't turn into that
i have thoughts along those lines every
day of my life i had that thought of
panera bread watching the people
eating their bread bowls with masks on
at the table and i thought i
might i hope my kid whatever happens
with my kid i hope they never turn into
that
the problem is when your concerns are
specifically racial
and gendered as though you're worried
that they'll be awful
because of their identity it's one thing
to acknowledge the fallen state of the
human race and our propensity for evil
it's another to imagine that your own
child is especially susceptible
to it based on their identity that's
called bigotry and yes
to be bigoted against your own flesh and
blood is deranged
beyond all imagining it's the type of
thought process
that has been made possible by the
critical race theory cult
one of the most basic strategies of any
cult is to turn
its members against their own families
now usually this involves turning
children
against parents and crt does that too
but the even more demented thing is to
turn parents against children
and then what about the books themselves
even many of the people criticizing this
video have still allowed that the books
are fine
in and of themselves it's just the
framing that's the problem but i
disagree
the books are a problem too first of all
she has
three books on consent three of them
that she'll begin reading to her child
from infancy
and remember she's not reading the books
in order to protect him
from being the victim of non-consensual
touching no this is all about stopping
stopping him from sexually assaulting
other people
this is a woman so worried that her son
will be a rapist
that she started him on an anti-rapist
curriculum from infancy
she might as well read him a book called
we eat dinner with people not people for
dinner in order to teach them how to not
be a cannibal
i mean she has imagined that her son is
at a very high risk of being an absolute
monster not just a bad person but a
monster
and now she'll spend most of her
maternal energy steering him away from
what she believes
is a near inevitability all you're
really doing at best is creating an
issue where it didn't exist
and introducing concepts where before
there was but childish innocence and
by the way in spite of the feminist
insistence that we need to teach our
sons not to rape
and they say that all the time right the
truth is
no you shouldn't need to specifically
teach that
i don't know about you there was never a
time in my life when my parents sat me
down and said now son
don't be a rapist any more than than
they ever sat me down and said now son
don't be an axe murderer they never said
either
of those things and yet i i became
neither an axe murderer nor a rapist why
well because they inculcated in me a
more complete
value system they taught me to respect
the dignity and value of other human
beings as well as my own
and they instilled virtue as well as
they could anyway
while warning against sin and vice and
so on when you do that with your
children
they will not grow up to be perfect
people but they will develop a moral
code and a system of values that will
direct them away from
things like rape and murder and
hopefully
it'll do a lot more than that it turns
out you should aim a lot higher than
just
don't be a rapist don't be awful
and when you aim higher when you aim for
actual virtue
the don't be awful and don't be a rapist
lesson is baked into the cake
you don't even need to say it or focus
on it
especially not when the kid is still in
diapers you damn fruitcake
as for the other two books or other
three um there was one telling the boy
that he should help clean around the
house
then there was another telling him that
he can play with whatever toys he wants
regardless of gender
those could be okay in and of themselves
depending on the specifics i haven't
read the book so i don't know
but this this mother is not reading
those books in order to open up
possibilities and to allow the child to
express himself
she has rather a very specific and rigid
idea of the sort of boy
she wants him to be she's already
labeled him he's a feminist
six months old he's already a feminist
she's decided that from birth
so although she says oh kids can
like whatever they want they can do
whatever they want in reality she has
made a box for him
and she will fit him into it one way or
another
now of course we all make boxes as
parents
for our kids we all have ideas of uh
about the sorts of people we want them
to be
that's what instilling values is all
about but the difference is that
progressive parents quote unquote have
an even narrower and more constricting
box
all while pretending that there's no box
at all
and that's the real problem and that's
why they are all canceled today
along with sarah
but not her poor child who uh is
certainly not canceled and is gonna need
all the
help he can get and i i fear for him and
so many other kids
and we will leave it on that uh
wonderful note today
have a great day god bless godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tulmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. today on the
ben shapiro show a spate of anti-semitic
attacks follows hamas's war on israel
while top democrats condemn
islamaphobia that's today on the bench
bureau show give it a listen
you